find the point B on segment AC such that
the ratio of a B to BC is 3 to 1 I
encourage you to pause this video and
try this on your own so let's think
about what they're asking so if that's
point C I'm just going to redraw this
line segment just to conceptualize what
they're asking for and that's point a
they're asking us to find some point B
some point B that the distance between C
and B so that's this distance right over
here so if this distance is X then this
is between B and a is going to be three
times that it's going to be three times
that so this will be 3x that the ratio
but the ratio of a B to B C is three to
one so that would be the ratio let me
write this down it would be a B it looks
like an HB it would be a B to B C is
going to be equal to three X to X which
is the same thing as three to one which
is the same thing as three to one if we
wanted to write it a slightly different
way so how can we think about it you
might be tempted to say oh well you
could use the distance formula find the
distance which by itself isn't
completely uncomplicated and then this
will be one-fourth of the way because if
you think about it this entire distance
is going to be 4x this entire distance
is going to be let me draw that a little
bit neater this entire distance if you
have an X plus a 3 X it's going to be 4x
so you say well this is one out of the
four X's along the way this is going to
be 1/4 of the distance between the two
points so this is let me write that down
this is 1/4 of the way 1/4 of the way
between C and B going from C sorry going
from C to a B is going to be 1/4 of the
way so maybe you try to find the
distance and you say well what are all
the points that are 1/4 away but it has
to be 1/4 of that distance away but then
it has to be on that line but that makes
it complicated because this is not this
is this line is an incline it's not just
horizontal it's not just vertical what
we can do however is break this problem
down into the vertical part the vertical
change between a and C and the
horizontal
between a and C so for example the
horizontal change between a and C a is
at 9 a is at nine right over here and C
is at negative seven C is at negative
seven so this distance right over here
is nine minus negative seven nine minus
negative seven which is equal to 9 plus
7 which is equal to 16 and you see that
here 9 plus 7 this total distance is 16
that's the horizontal distance change
going from A to C or going from C to a
and the vertical change and you could
even just count that that's going to be
4 C is that one a is that a is at five
going from one to five
you've changed vertically 4 so what we
can say going from C to B in each
direction in the vertical direction and
the horizontal direction we're going to
go 1/4 of the way so if we go 1/4 in the
vertical direction we're going to end up
we're going to end up at Y is equal to 2
and if we go so I'm just going starting
at C 1/4 of the way 1/4 of 4 is 1 so
I've just moved up one so our so our Y
is going to be equal to 2 and if we go
1/4 in the horizontal direction 1/4 of
16 is 4 so we go 1 2 3 4 so we end up
right over here our X is negative 3 so
we end up at that point right over there
we end up at this point this is the
point negative 3 comma 2 and if you are
really careful with your drawing you
could have actually just drawn actually
you don't have to be that careful since
this is graph paper you actually could
have just said hey look we would go 1/4
this way and where does that intersect
the line hey it intersects the line
right over there or you could have said
we're going to go 1/4 this way where
does that intersect the line and that
would have let you figure it out either
way so this point right over here is B
it is 1/4 of the it is 1/4 of the way
between C and a or another way of
thinking about the distance between C
and B which we haven't even figured out
we could do that using the distance
formula or the pathetic
theorem which it really is we could this
distance the distance CB is one third of
the distance
ba or ba the ratio of a B a B to B C is
three to one